thème les hommes virils qu'est ce que tu
veux karim et leïla est venu pour faire
cette émission je vous le dis pour être
au sein de l'émission pour donner son
avis également pour pécho donc animal
est devenue chaude à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il a mangé la bouche à la marocaine vous
êtes notre diamant vous êtes tokyo koen
aux cgu merci non je déconne verts
valérie bénaïm vous vous êtes gentil et
que tout le monde nous mêmes mais
marchés d'actions avec tout le monde
commence maintenant
ta gueule toi maintenant une rebelle
regarder le nouveau look de valérie
bénaïm à l'état
[Applaudissements]
les blues à trouver motif ils ont tant
merde aux joies du latin portage en
arrière de son ordi acheté la wc
changerait légal
vas-y prenait encore laquelle ma gueule
je sors ma gueule ça change rien je suis
dit je m'en fout ta gueule aucune jérémy
sokona vous avez triché
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
soit les boules
[Applaudissements]
allez
or voilà
[Applaudissements]